Racquel: How can I see these guys
Racquel: on the inside as human beings?
♪
Racquel: I can understand
Racquel: how you're just reduced to something that
was a mistake.
Reggie: Life is not a straight line and it's a maze.
Orlando: There's a larger story at play
Orlando: about resistance.
Orlando: That's what the boys left us with. Right?
Resist.
♪
Reggie: One of our central questions is are we truly free
Reggie: when our brothers and sisters are not free?
Character: What happens to a dream deferred?
Dr. John Carlos: There are more black people
in the penitentiaries across this nation
Dr. John Carlos: then there were black people enslaved
before the civil war.
I've never done anything like this before.
Dr. John Carlos: So for me to walk in, man and digest
Dr. John Carlos: a script that they gave me,
Dr. John Carlos: was challenging for me.
I have this history or legacy. It's about humanity.
Dr. John Carlos: When we came together
Dr. John Carlos: we could move a mountain.
Reggie: This has been a unique treat because we bring
a lot of the incarcerated people
Reggie: front and center.
Reggie: We really, really get to meet them,
Reggie:  just real life human beings.
Our students are future scientists
and this semester they're working with bee colonies
and understanding how bees help the earth.
♪
Reggie: I really just love like the idea of bees.
Reggie: It's a really interesting juxtaposition of
Reggie: young black men in that environment.
Reggie:  You might say that they're dangerous and bad.
Reggie: But the planet needs them,
Reggie: they help the world be better.
Racquel: Vince was a really great entry point to that
because they know him.
Racquel: You're not just an awful person,
Racquel: you have layers. And that was really, really
Racquel: important for me to get through because
I even did a stint in jail when I was like their age.
Racquel: I'm very much into redemption
I mean, I am that.
So there's no way I wouldn't want people
to see that in these characters.
You are not your biggest mistake.
That really means something
I'm glad
♪
Reggie: The other amazing thing that happens
Reggie: is that they play a basketball game
Reggie: against a team comprised of these incarcerated
Reggie: young men. As we started doing rehearsals,
Reggie: I just kept saying but guys,
Reggie: like what if we just do it all in one shot?
John: Reggie was referencing that film on 1917,
John: which is shot by one of the greatest DP's ever.
John: I think they won the Oscar for that film.
So I'm like, yeah, no, we'll do that.
No problem, me? Oh, yeah. Easy.
John: I already do camera workouts,
John: but the way he was describing it,
John: I'm like, I guess I just need to like
John: double my workouts for the next the month,
which I started doing.
John: so we see it from the back. Yeah.
So you're down there when that shot goes up.
Crew Member:  All the background
Crew Member:  go behind that tree over there please.
Reggie: It was like 6 minutes of just holding a camera up.
Reggie: And it was really, you know,
Reggie: technically just an amazing cinematic feat
Reggie: that we were able to pull that off.
♪
Reggie: As much as I like to say,
Reggie: this is not solely a basketball show,
Reggie: basketball is important.
Reggie: Really, love this idea of it
Reggie: have to get the audience at the edge of their seat
Reggie: and while they're leaning forward
Reggie: hit them with the truth.
♪